[Music]
hey wisecrack
michael here today we're looking at a
cartoon after our own hearts a show that
combines sober discussions of philosophy
with zombie hordes parasitic clown
spiders and magic wielding fish men
netflix is the midnight gospel a
co-production of comedian duncan
trussell and adventure time creator
pendleton ward
the midnight gospel combines audio clips
from trestle's long-running podcast the
duncan trestle family hour with
ward signature visual storytelling to
create a one-of-a-kind animated series
that is equal parts trippy hilarious and
terrifying
but is the show just a compendium of
shower thoughts to help your furlough go
down easier
or is it a legitimate dive into
quote-unquote real philosophy
to find out we're going to focus on one
specific aspect of the show
if you've seen it already you might have
noticed one of tressel's favorite
subjects popping up repeatedly
in buddhism the idea is all of those
mental
forms of analysis that's right buddhism
the midnight gospel asks us to consider
what are the implications of buddhist
philosophy for people going about their
everyday lives
should you become a societal dropout
just like the protagonist clancy or is
there more to life than just micro
dosing and doing ritual magic
well we're about to find out so select
your avatars merge with your simulators
and follow us as we
rocket into this wisecrack edition on
the midnight gospel
deep or dumb as always spoilers ahead
and now a quick recap the plot of the
midnight gospel and so far as a show
about ionic multiverse simulators can be
said to have a plot
centers on clancy a music-loving burnout
living in a trailer on the chromatic
ribbon
on the ribbon clancy and other
simulation farmers spend their days
shoving their heads into the
aforementioned vulva matrices hoping to
collect profitable artifacts or
marketable experiences from the
multiverse within
clancy for instance uses his trips to
gather content for his pet project
a spacecast with a single subscriber and
to my one
subscriber hernock jensen i live for you
you're the reason i wake up in the
morning with a smile on my face
clancy's spacecast takes the form of
interviews with subjects from wacky
dying worlds usually centered around
topics such as eastern philosophy the
occult
or anything else worthy of a keanu
reeves
said conversations use repurposed audio
from trussel's actual interviews with
people like dr drew pinsky and anne
lamott
from the beginning clancy prioritizes
thinking about and discussing these big
ideas
over more practical concerns such as
problems in his personal life or the
day-to-day operations of his simulator
on an admittedly simulated planet
overrun by zombies for instance he is so
unconcerned with what's going on around
him
that he continues to talk about the
positive benefits of mindfulness
meditation
while a man is eaten alive in front of
his pregnant wife they say look at it as
though you're sitting in a forest
and you're getting to watch a rare
animal
walking out and they're clearing
clancy avoids mundane tasks like reading
the instruction manual for his simulator
dismissing them as distractions from his
contemplation of the deeper truths of
existence
good morning master did you get a chance
to read the universe simulator
faq i left in your inbox nope
specifically
clancy through his passing familiarity
with eastern religious traditions
has come to believe that the material
world is unimportant
or even illusory then you become pure
awareness and the concept is that is
what we
really are yeah and that this entire
material universe including our body is
a kind of fin phenomenon i can't say
it's phenomenological phenomenological
field of phenomena a field of phenomena
being encapsulated within
put simply clancy is saying the tangible
universe that we can see
hear touch etc is just an imperfect
manifestation of a more fundamental
reality
accessible through consciousness
altering practices like meditation
ritual plants medicine and so on
therefore the material world
can and ought to be ignored avoided or
ideally
transcended everyday life with its bills
shitty neighbors and absurd laws
isn't the full experience of divinity
enlightenment or whatever you want to
call it
therefore it's crap so here's the
question
are clancy's thoughts on eastern
religious philosophy deep or
more like the inane ramblings of someone
who just escaped their first alan watts
youtube rabbit hole
to answer that question we need to ask
does clancy's line of reasoning fit
within a buddhist context
that is do his beliefs hold water among
buddhist philosophers with a smidge more
experience
well yes and no let's start with the
idea that the world is unimportant and
illusory
according to the dalai lama this is
somewhat correct but
only half the picture when it comes to
living by the tenets of buddhism
in mind science a collection of essays
and dialogues the dalai lama contends
that there are two levels of truth in
the buddhist world
one an ultimate truth subscribed to by
clancy and your stoner roommate
which acknowledges the emptiness of an
impermanence among all
things and two a relative truth having
to do with the
facts of existence as they relate to our
daily lives both of these truths are
equally important to living a good life
at least within the particular version
of tibetan buddhism the dalai lama
represents the relative world with all
its disappointments
frustrations and heartaches is not
merely some illusion to be seen through
this is contra clancy who tries to
sidestep the problems of the material
world by fleeing to some supposedly
higher plane of existence the dalai lama
accepts the reality not
only of the subjective world of the mind
but also of the external objects of the
physical world
in other words while the mind-blowing
cosmic insights gained through
meditation
and or study in the buddhist tradition
are all well and good they are not an
excuse to [ __ ] off to a trailer
somewhere and abandon one's
responsibilities
which is what clancy has decided to do
as his computer points out to him
master it's become clear to me that
you've been avoiding with the real
world by going in my goddamn if the show
were merely to stop here
we'd be forced to call dumb on this
delightfully bizarre series
getting half of buddhism right at the
expense of the other half is not in
philosophical terms
cool but the show doesn't stop there
instead it explores how the pure
universal truth approach to life does
not qualify as enlightenment
on the contrary it creates very real
harm
throughout much of the series clancy's
disdain for the material world
keeps coming back to bite him in the ass
early on we learned that clancy's
dismissive attitude towards humdrum
everyday life has begun to affect his
relationships
for instance he is funding his spacecast
ambitions with money borrowed from his
sister
who explicitly told him not to blow it
on a multiverse simulator as i
stare out at this majestic scene i can't
help but think of my sister sarah
you said clancy i'll loan you this money
but you have to promise not to spend her
on a used universe simulator
he ignores her attempts to call him
which rightfully pisses her off
clancy it's your sister you need to call
me back right
now i'm freaking peeved off man there's
no reason that you're
fake what's more by repeatedly ignoring
his computer's request for basic
maintenance he winds up damaging most of
the worlds in his simulator before he
even gets the chance to visit them
due to operator error there are no
longer living things on this planet
what about this one all this avoidance
doesn't help clancy transcend the very
real problems of his busted computer
broken family ties and a weak ass space
cast in search of the ultimate truth
clancy has forgotten the relative truths
and nuisances
of everyday existence which no matter
how much ayahuasca you chug
have a funny way of hanging around until
you actually do something about them
when clancy's sister finally gets
through to him she explains that she
doesn't even care about the money
anymore i love you
and if this is about the money you don't
need to pay me back
she's just worried about her brother and
how his refusal to face up to his role
in the world is hurting him
this confrontation with the real world
puts an unprepared clancy in a full-on
sweaty panic attack which he follows
with an
angry outburst against the one person
who cares enough to check up on him
voicemail full message not received
clearly clancy isn't finding lasting
peace and happiness from taking
refuge in the platitudes around ultimate
truth favored by hermits
burning man attendees and jedi to
achieve what we might call
real enlightenment within a buddhist
framework sentient beings like clancy
and
like us also have to come to terms with
the painful
sometimes downright nasty facts of
physical existence and to do that we
need to look at
zombies no seriously in his book dharma
of the dead
scholar christopher m mormon explores
some of the parallels between zombie
fiction and buddhism
particularly important for our purposes
he demonstrates how your typical
glass-eyed zombie wandering around in a
stupor can serve as a model for one of
the potential pitfalls of meditation
practice
the deliberate cultivation of a
pleasantly numb trance-like
state of being devoid of mindful
attention fictional zombies in other
words
can represent one of the very real
dangers of sloppy or misdirected
spirituality
zombies can be a metaphor for those
practitioners of a given tradition who
try their damnedest to paper over the
difficulties of relative existence
with ultimate truths about god the
universe or whatever else is in that
pamphlet they're shoving in your face
from the dalai lama's point of view this
kind of zombie zen existence would seem
to stand in stark contrast
to the real goal of meditation
cultivating a moment-to-moment
engagement with the present
also known as mindfulness in describing
the difference between helpful practice
and self-imposed zombification
mormon also notes a parallel between
core tenants of buddhism and philosopher
martin heidegger's concept of design
dozen is heidegger's term for the
uniquely human experience of existence
in describing the parallels between this
thinking and buddhism
mormon contends that according to
heidegger the authentic
self is that which acknowledges its own
mortality and incorporates it
the inauthentic self is one that denies
death and flees it
here dozen sounds much like the buddhist
anata a different perspective on
selfhood that acknowledges the truth of
its impermanence
so what does that mean for our favorite
space caster put simply
clancy can laser focus on the ultimate
truth rhapsodize about phenomenological
fields and be a dick to his sister as
much as he pleases
but doing those things will not help him
become an authentic self
like everyone else in the universe
clancy is an anata
a not-self which is to say a being
subject to change
including discomfort and eventual
non-existence authentic living follows
not from a narrow
emphasis on the wonderful things in life
its beauty and pattern for instance
but from an ongoing acceptance and
integration of its sheer aspects such as
pain
violence and death which is not to say
that buddhism is all doom and gloom
far from it through his interview
subjects clancy comes to realize that a
worldview which integrates both a love
of life and a deep awareness of death is
the gateway to a precious mode of being
which he could never
access through his spacecast alone in
other words he starts to care about the
world outside his simulator as a
valuable part
of existence in and of itself over the
course of his journey he comes to accept
the
at first glance contradictory notion
that struggling with life's hardships
can bring immense pain
but can also bring a profound peace that
isn't so affected by the ups and downs
of the multiverse
for example during one of trussel
clancy's podcast interviews
buddhist teacher trudy goodman rides
through a graveyard while explaining
that
time of death is uncertain but death is
certain
if we really got that we would have
fewer of the kind of moments where we
regret having wasted
our time or somebody else's and it's so
precious and
just as horrible and brutal as the world
can be it's
gorgeous and exquisite but the point
really hits home for clancy when the
multiverse simulator brings him in
contact with his mother
voiced by duncan trussell's real-life
mom deneen fendig
who passed away of cancer in 2013. as
part of a
heartbreaking scene in which clancy and
his mom undergo a full life
death and rebirth together danine
explains how she's holding up so well
despite her diagnosis
the reason i look better now than i ever
have is because
i am more fully living right because i'm
living and dying
consciously simultaneously i'm holding
both
in a similar way clancy finally arrives
at a degree of authenticity by dropping
his pretensions and learning to engage
in his own life
mess and all even though your life is
out of tune
you can still sing along with it
and it's better to be you and out of
tune
than acting like someone else who has
found enlightenment
to put it another way clancy learns to
embody
both the ultimate truth he's so stoked
about and the relative truth that the
dalai lama or heidegger would argue is
so
vital to human existence we see his new
awareness play out in the final moments
of the series when a raid on clancy's
unlicensed simulation farm ends with
clancy and his dog diving all the way
into the simulator to escape the feds
moments later clancy winds up on a bus
surrounded by the people he's
interviewed throughout the series
this is a situation that ultimate truth
clancy could dissect for hours
is this the afterlife is he still in the
simulator
what the ever loving [ __ ] is going on
with the driver playing the spoons
but instead we see clancy experience a
real moment of awareness and clarity
after walking to the back of the bus
clancy halfheartedly starts to interview
a stranger
you mind if i interview you for my um
am i dead only to realize that something
way more important than the space cast
is happening right in front of him
the man in the robe turns out to be rom
das a practitioner of eastern meditation
techniques and one of tressel's heroes
who answers clancy's questions by saying
just
be here now in other words clancy rides
off into eternity with the knowledge
that a more specific answer to his
question
doesn't really matter if and when the
bus reaches its final destination
whatever's waiting at the end can take
care of itself
what's really important right now is
focusing his attention on every precious
moment
and that seems way closer to whatever
real enlightenment looks like
which is why graveyard penis
notwithstanding
the series earns a solid deep from us so
what do you think wisecrack
have we oversold this kooky cartoon or
is it even more brilliant than we are
giving it credit for
let us know in the comments below and be
sure to subscribe and ring that bell
big thanks to our patrons for supporting
the channel and our podcast
thanks for watching guys later
[Music]
you